hey everybody uh thanks for joining us
today
um before we get to our speaker
presentation i want to give a very
important announcement that we're
excited to uh share real quick so
um my name is garrett genther i am with
the cell analysis division of agilent
technologies
and today we wanted to uh share with you
guys
our newest development in flow cytometry
the novosite pention
flow cytometer so just a brief
background if you guys haven't been
familiar with agilent
flow cytometers basically it was um the
first
cytometer was launched in 2014 under ac
of biosciences and
over the course of the next few years uh
we've been able to offer additional
capabilities and also additional
technology advancements to flow
cytometry so this includes
uh the novocite quantion and the
novosite advantion that have been
launched in 2018 and 2019 respectively
and then today i'm announcing the
newest cytometer to the family of the
novacite pention
so the novosite pention is a five laser
30 channel uh fluorescent cytometer
building upon
the technology built in the um with the
novosite quantion
and when we look at the other cytometers
available on the market
in the four laser or five laser space
the quantion and the
pention offer more channels which
equates to more flexibility for you and
our cytometers are upgradable so
quantion a four laser nova site quantion
can easily be upgradeable to a five
laser
nova site pention system still using um
the advanced
technology so what is that advanced
technology if some of you guys
haven't been um involved or
heard about the novosite quantion before
traditional technology for
detectors in flow cytometers has been um
using uh pmts or photomultiplier tubes
with some of this advanced technology we
can achieve much more sensitivity in the
detection of these
fluorescents the emitted fluorescence
light
one of these detectors is called a
silicon photomultiplier
it's a solid-state photon level
sensitive device and it's
really um it's well known for its high
quantum efficiency
you can have high gain and it's very
robust even
you know so these are produced by
hamamatsu and even they
are very excited about them it's on the
the you know first
uh sorry their landing page on on the
website
so um it's a really good technology
we've been using it for a couple years
now and
um we've seen very very good results in
terms of sensitivity using these
detectors
and so when we look at the uv channels
that are now with the
novocite pention so the pention will
include a uv laser
a violet laser blue yellow and red laser
the performance that we're seeing out of
the uv laser with these
advanced detectors is really nice so at
the top here i just have this is a quick
quick plots showing you six peak beads
in the separation there
but we also did some comparison with
other instruments out on the market
using the actual fluorochromes
conjugated to cd4
and then bound to compensation beads
so in these channels we were able to run
run these samples and with these various
fluorochromes listed
and then calculate the stain index so
on the middle column is the stain index
from the novacite pention and on the
right-hand column is a stain index from
a competitor instrument
and you can see with some of these
brilliant uv dies
we can see a three-fold increase like
with buv 395
or a two-fold increase in the stain
index like with buv 496 and 661
now we couldn't provide a comparison to
all the channels because not all
instruments offer as many channels as
the nova site pention
now sensitivity is really important in
terms of being able to detect these dim
signals that you may have on your cells
but also fluidic stability is
really important in terms of
reproducibility
and delivering consistent results so
so when we look at the fluidic design of
the novosites
line of flow cytometers compared to our
competitor instruments
we see that no matter if you're running
your sample speed at slow
or fast we still see a really really uh
tight cv
so cv is going to be the measurement of
your
the the variation in the signal
detection and when you have a higher cv
you tend to get more spread
in in your signal on the with the nova
site pention on the left hand plot
you see even at low speed medium speed
and fast speed
there's a marginal increase in in the cv
which would be expected but it's it's
very little we're still seeing cvs below
five percent even at the high speed
high sample speed um flow rate
whereas in the competitor instrument
when you go from low to medium to fast
you actually see a
rapid increase in the cvs cvs as high as
15
20 25 percent which is really going to
produce more spread
in your in in your samples
and the specific signal detection
included with all of our nova site line
of flow cytometers
is the very very intuitive and powerful
novo express software
this is acquisition and data analysis
software
um to provide you with as many automatic
features as possible like automatic
report generation we have a cell cycle
analysis module
um cell proliferation module heat map
display
all of these really to make the data
acquisition and analysis
as easy as possible
and automating
these systems is very easy we can either
use an auto sampler or we can
attach this flow cytometer to a robot
itself
so um the auto sampler can accommodate
42 racks 96 well plates 384 well plates
has an integrated barcode reader and it
really provides walk away functionality
so you can set a plate up on
set a plate on the system push run and
walk away and
be confident that you'll get good
results when you return and if you want
to
increase your throughput even more you
can connect it to a
robotic platform
i just want to show you some quick
preliminary data that we've
been able to generate using the novosite
pention this was a 24
color panel analyzing whole blood
and looking at a different uh immune
cell subtypes
um here's a list of all the markers i
don't have enough time this
uh today to go through all of them but i
just want to highlight a few of them to
you
so as you can imagine a 24 color panel
can get really really complicated and
a little bit hard to display um all the
plots at once
in one slide so i'm going to focus in on
some of these t-cell differentiation
markers that we've been able to look at
so when we zoom in on these up in the um
on the left hand side we have our gating
strategy for
identifying the lymphocyte population
separating those into t
and b cells and then in the um upper
right plot we're looking at the gamma
delta t cells and this one is using a
one of the brilliant uv markers on the
x-axis
and you can see that there's really good
separation between the positive and the
negative samples on the right the shaded
blue and green areas
we're looking at different t-cell
differentiation markers in the cd8 and
cd4
cell populations looking at you know
central memory naive effector memory and
effector memory ra positive cd45ra
positive cells
up at the top where the cd8 um
cd8 subsets and right underneath it is a
cd4 subset and you can see that
these profiles differ um pretty
significantly
between these two different types of t
cells
and one other population i want to point
out in the lower right hand corner
you see that there's um we're looking at
the t regs so these are defined by cd
25 positive cells that are also cd 20
cd 127 low and you can see this
population
isolated here in the lower right hand
corner so
um as you can imagine you know
this 24 color analysis get can get
really really complicated
and but you can use some advanced
analysis features
in order to um in order to tease out
some of the differences
in these immune cell subsets like tisney
or spade
and whatnot so so with that um
i just uh want to let's see
i just want to thank you for your time
and um i
want to now introduce dr laura compania
she has received her phd in cellular and
molecular immunology
focusing on the role of macrophages in
tumor
and autoimmune diseases she is currently
at the university of edinburgh
dividing her time between her passion
for teaching
as well as her passion for understanding
macrophage functions in various disease
states so
today i would like to welcome dr pena
hello everyone and thanks for joining us
first of all i would like to thank the
organizer for giving us the opportunity
to share our data here today
the project i'm going to introduce you
today
relates to the study of the role of
status phosphorylation in macrophage
phagocytosis as a potential therapeutic
target
in acute liver injury we first
introduce briefly what macrophage
phagocytosis is
and why it could be a potential
therapeutic target
in acute liver injury i will then move
to show you some results
about the prophygic role of phosphostate
tree in macrophages and
how phosphorostatory controls autophagy
and prevents
immunosine essence in macrophages
i will then move to show you and discuss
with you
our working model and there will be then
time for the q and a
part phagocytosis is all about a new
topic
it was discovered over a hundred years
ago by elijah machnikov
but despite the elijah mahnikov already
defined
it as the one constant element in
immunity
whether innate or acquired there is
still
lots that we don't know about
phagocytosis
particularly we don't know what happens
to the macrophage
after it has ingested its phagocytic
cargo
in this presentation i will use the word
apherocytosis
to refer specifically to the
phagocytosis of dead or dying cells
by a live macrophage and i will define
macrophages as professional phagocytes
as
they are cells that perform phagocytosis
and nephrocytosis with
high efficiency studying phagocytosis is
crucial
in fact inefficient pharcocytosis
is associated with recurrent infections
as you can see here
on the right hand side of your screen
patients with copd
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
have a recurrent infection and their
pulmonary macrophages are less able to
phagocytos than those of healthy
patients
also autoimmune diseases can develop
as a result of inefficient
phagocytosis but what is exactly
phagocytosis
and particularly ephrocytosis the
phagocytosis
or of dead or dying cells phagocytosis
starts
with the sensing of the dead or dying
cells
here indicated by a pink style the
macrophage
is attracted to the dead or dying cells
by
finding signals which are soluble
molecules secreted or released
by the dead cell here on the
bottom right hand side of the micrograph
you can see a macrophage that is
protruding
its membrane around the dead or dying
cell
this is the phase of engulfing when the
dead cell exposes on its surface the
so-called it me signal
cell surface molecule that are engaged
by
receptor on the macrophage cell membrane
forming the so-called apoptotic synapse
the macrophage then moved to internalize
the cell
as you can see here we know
much less about this phase of
phagocytosis and what we know about the
previous uh steps of phagocytosis
in fact there are no the so-called
so-called internalize me signal
what we know though is that for this
phase to happen
the phagosome has to form and
progressively be acidified
and this is a key because we can move
from the phase of internalization to the
phase of digestion
of the phagocytosed that cell
when the phagosome fuses with the
lysosome and
the phagocytal cells is dismembered
but what has it all to do with acute
liver injury and
why are we interested in acute liver
injury
we define acute liver injury as a single
head
to a liver that cause a damage
and by far and wide both in the us and
the uk
the single major cause of
hospitalization
following acute liver injury is
acetaminophen
also known as paracetamol overdose
when acetaminophen or apart for short is
ingested at therapeutic doses it is
normally
very safely metabolized by the liver and
is then excreted by via bile
or urine however if
the app is ingested in
a toxic dose in an overdose it is
metabolized
in the liver by the sip2e1 enzyme
a member of the cytochrome p450 family
and converted into into this
intermediate
molecule called naphthquim napkin can
rapidly conjugate the glutathione
and if in excess it can rapidly deplete
all the glutathione pool of the cell
inducing
oxidative stress furthermore napquick
can
conjugate with other cellular
macromolecule for example phospholipids
and the two pathway converge
into inducing the apothocyte cell death
by necrosis it is a methoxylinase in
staining
you can see indicated by cv the central
vein of the liver
surrounded by an aerial necrosis that is
indicated by the black arrow
and you can clearly see the striking
difference by the healthy parenchyma
indicated here by the p
and the necrotic areas where hardly any
healthy pathosite can be found and this
can give a hand
why macrophages and particularly
macrophage phagocytosis can be crucial
in this setting in the case of a liver
damage
of any kind the
hepatocytes in the liver die and
inflammation follows
the first cells to come to the liver are
the neutrophils
that die in situ once they're spent the
second wave of inflammatory cells coming
into the liver
is represented by macrophages that are
able to scavenge
both that hepatocytes and that
neutrophil
this apherocytosis is instrumental for
the conversion of the macrophage
phenotype from pro-inflammatory to
pro-restorative
and to liver regeneration
however when an overdose of apa occurs
the liver damage is extensive and the
number of that hypothesis increases
and these uh creates an a very extensive
inflammatory reaction with an increased
number
of neutrophils that infiltrate the liver
this means an extra work for the
macrophage that i have to scavenge
more than the pathocytes and more than
neutrophils
a particular phenomenon that we observe
in the liver of apaf overdosed mice
is that the resident cells resident
macrophages of the liver also known as
copper cells are depleted
and instead they're replaced by a wave
of
infiltrating macrophages that are
monocyte derived macrophages
this latter population though is much
less efficient at performing
phagocytosis than the resident
macrophages
so basically during apap overdose we
find ourselves
for reason that are still purely
understood in a situation in which we
have
lots of macrophages that are not able to
perform phagocytosis efficiently
and this leads to a lower percentage of
macrophages converting their phenotype
into pro-restorative macrophages
and decrease liver regeneration
in order to study macrophages in acute
liver injury we
make use of this particular mouse model
the
this is a mouse the locked expression of
the molecule gpnb
gpn mb is a one transmembrane protein
that is instrumental for
the maturation of the phagosome
therefore macrophages lacking gpmb
can internalize the phagocytic cargo
like the macrophage on the left-hand
side of your screen
but they cannot digest it so they cannot
become like the macrophage
in the on the right hand side of your
screen
these mice lack the expression of gpnb
because the stop codon
that is the result of a spontaneous
mutation is introduced
uh in in place of an arginine in
position 150
which is very close to the n-terminal of
this protein
therefore the protein is non-functional
and the phagosome cannot mature
if we uh treated the gpnb proficient
versus gpnb deficient mice
we demised to moderate overdose of a pub
of 300 mega per kig
and we then harvest the levers a various
time point
after the overdose we are able to
compare the
necrosis extent uh in
the two strains of mice as you can see
at eight hours there is a trend
towards having a bit more necrosis in
the gpm and be efficient nice
however this difference is not
significant and the difference is also
not significant
at 10 and 36 hours however
at 60 hours when the gpmb proficient
macrophages sorry mice have completely
healed their liver
as you can see from the hematoxylin as
in staining below
the gp and mb deficient mice that are
that have macrophages enabled to the
justification
still have extensive necrosis
extensive necrosis um can be the
uh the result of lower hypothesis
proliferation higher pesticide cell
death
or reduce macrophage phagocytosis and
wound healing functions
our studies seem to indicate that
proliferation of hepatocytes is not the
matter here
and hepatocytes that do not seem to er
eat to die more um to start with
as you can see at 10 and 36 hour as we
said the necrosis is absolutely
comparable
in the two groups of mice therefore we
um are leaning to think that whenever
macrophages are inefficient for
phagocytosis
even multi-moderate overdose of the
paracetamol can result
in a failed liver regeneration therefore
our working hypothesis is that it is
crucial to understand the molecular
pathways that keep focusing
is efficient and this is instrumental to
identify potential therapeutic targets
to improve
the outcome in patients with acute liver
injury
in 2018 we published a paper in which we
showed that one of those
pro phagocytic pathway is the
phosphorylation of statory
following the phosphorylation of
structuring in inflammatory macrophages
performing aphorocytosis
the macrophages are able to convert
their phenotype to a restorative
phenotype
also the correct expression of
saturated phosphorylation is crucial to
time
a pathocyte proliferation so that
hepatocytes can proliferate
only after the liver has been cleared
from
all the um necrotic
tissue in order to perform this study
we decided not to use western blood
because with the western blot you can
only analyze the bulk of cells that
perform phagocytosis
but you cannot distinguish in your bulk
the macrophages that have
from the macrophage that have not
performed phagocytosis
before we decided to use a flow
cytometry approach in which
we can label the phagocytic meal with a
fluorescent
dye and we can therefore recognize
specifically
which macrophages are performing
phagocytosis and
interrogate only these subpopulation
for the expression of the phosphorylated
star tree
in order to analyze multiple time points
and genotypes or treatments at the same
time
we also developed a medium throughput
screening flow cytometry assay
that i'm going to describe to you
in a minute the base for this
assay is a simple flow cytometry
assay in which macrophages are labeled
with
any macrophage cell surface marker we
use by way of example here
cd11b and the meal is in this case
is apoptotic thymocytes is labeled with
the dye
which in this case is tmtmr and the
double positive cells
are those macrophages that have
internalized the phagocytic cargo
in with this assay we are able to
analyze multiple time points and
multiple phagocytosis to target ratio
ranging one in two to one in 20. unless
otherwise stated
all the experiments you will see here
are performed with a phagocyte at the
target ratio of one in five
on the right hand side of your screen
you can see the result of our first
experiment done with this assay
and in this assay uh we have measured
the phagocytosis by gpnb proficient and
gpnb deficient
bone marrow derived macrophages and as
you can see
the proficient macrophages that are
proficient for phagocytic cargo
are increasingly able to phagocytose
over time
while the gpnb deficient mice that are
deficient for the fatigue acidic cargo
are not
we then we then moved this assay from
the single tubes into a 96 well plate
we mixed the bombardier macrophages and
the apoptotic
aside the label within cmtmr uh
in a ratio one in five and we analyze
phagocytosis
and start rephosphorylation at distinct
time points
briefly what we do is that we label the
cells at the end of phagocytosis we fix
them
permeabilize them and we perform the
intracellular staining
when they wash the cells
from annex sustaining and we read them
using the novosite 3000 and we analyze
the data
using the novexpress software as a
negative control we use the fat ma bone
marrow derived macrophages treated with
cytokines in d
and also unfed bone marrow derived
macrophages
the first uh experiment we performed
was we did with this platform uh
was a time course using bone marrow
derived
wall type macrophages fed with apoptotic
cell in a ratio one in five
and we analyzed the phosphorylation of
star 3
at 15 30 60 and 120 minutes
after the start of phagocytosis and we
perform
the uh analysis only in the gate of
phagocytosing macrophages
and as you can see saturi is
phosphorylated early on during
phagocytosis
the phosphorylation is maintained at 30
and 60 minutes before declining around
the under 20 minute time point
we then moved to compare the gp mb
proficient and deficient mice
to see whether the gp and b deficient
mice were less able to
phosphorylate statory upon uh ingestion
of the phagocytic cargo
interestingly both the gp and mb
proficient and deficient mice
are initially able to phosphorylate star
3 as you can see here
7 and 15 minutes however the gpmb
deficient mice
have a progressive and faster decline in
the phosphorylational structure
probably as a result of their lower
ability to digest and process the
phagocytic cargo
and the from this experiment we could
conclude that the cargo digestion
partially control
phosphorylation of statory during
apherocytosis
we then moved to analyze
whether these lower activation of
statory had any functional meaning
and in order to do so we perform uh
enough in which we took
wall type of bone marrow derived
macrophages and we treated them
with a pharmacological inhibitor of
stuttering to verify whether this
induced
any uh functional defect in the
macrophages
we use two different approaches one uh
we
for the first experiment we use the live
imaging and then we confirm the result
using the phagocytosis assay i've just
described you
and as you can see here cells that are
macrophages that are treated with the
phosphostate inhibitor are less able to
perform phagocytosis
as compared with the vehicle-treated
counterparts
interestingly if il-6 is added to the
cell culture
as a mean to exogenously stimulate
staffordy
the phenotype is partially rescued at
the time of the publication of this
paper however
we couldn't quite make up why
fosusta 3 had these prophagositic
functions in macrophages
so moving forward in the project we
considered we focused
on what is a macrophage unique challenge
among
all other cells in our body macrophages
have to recycle
a sheer amount of other cells waste when
they
efforocytose them and
one pathway that is ubiquitous
ubiquitously used
by all cells in our organs and tissue to
cope with
cell stress is autophagy autophagy is
a way in which the cells when are in a
need in an energetic deficit
can recycle their own organelles and
uh therefore can um survive
a certain stress macrophages are
probably not different from any other
cells so if they are in the steady state
as something perturbs then
perturbs them they are able to induce
autophagy
before we started to hypothesize that
probably what phosphostatry does
is that induces a short boots of
bustover or
autophagy in the phagocytosis
phagocytosing macrophage
and this allows the macrophage to become
or to maintain its phagocytosis
efficiency
the link between autophagy and
phagocytosis is by no means new
and there are several papers out there
pointing out
at a relationship between activation of
profit of autophagy and
efficiency of the phagocytic process
however
the mechanisms that link the activation
of the of autophagy
and the maintenance of phagocytosis
efficiency
is still poorly understood and we
hypothesized that the phosphostate and
cargo digestion
are indeed linked to the activation of
autophagy
in order to prove this hypothesis
we took bone marrow dry macrophages from
gpnb proficient and deficient mice
we sorted using fact sorting the
phagocytosing gpnb proficient or gpnb
deficient mice we extracted rna
and analyzed the expression of a number
of autophagy related genes
and as you can see in gpnb
deficient mice macrophages which i
remember you
are deficient for cargo digestion
a number of autophagy genes are less
expressed
including amber one and dark one which
has which are exquisitely
autophagy specific genes we also
performed
an electron microscopy analysis and we
counted
the number of early autovesicles and
later the vesicle
per macrophage the yellow arrow
indicates what an early autophysical
looks like
and the red arrows indicate what a later
the vesicle
looks like and we quantified
the early or late autovesicles in
macrophage that didn't perform
phagocytosis
or that are in early or late
phagocytosis
and as you can see from the central
panel macrophages that are in early
phagocytosis which basically are
macrophages like the one you see
in the micrographs reported here
um they have a lower number of later to
vesicles
so this convinced us that macrophages
activate autophagy
following the digestion of the
phagocytic cargo
now if this is phosphostatory dependent
we should see a similar phenotype in
wild type macrophages that we treated
with an inhibitor of associatory
as you can see here from the
quantification
of the early and the later
autophagosomes uh
bone marrow-derived wild-type
macrophages that have been treated with
a pharmacological inhibitor of statory
during phagocytosis
indeed they have a lower number of
latest autophysical mirroring what
happened
in the gpmb deficient macrophages
interestingly if we add io6 to the cell
culture
as a means to stimulate exogenously the
phosphorylation of statory
the number of uh later the vesicle is
restored
and i remember you the tile six was also
able to restore
the uh function the fungusitive function
of these macrophages
we then um discussed this data
with this colleague of mine who is an
exceptionally talented
postdoc sofia who is very interested in
studying
cellular senescence and she pointed out
that my phosphostate inhibitor treated
macrophages very much
showed um patonyamic sign of senescence
which are those electron dense
accumulation that you can see here in
the picture
um indicated by the pink arrow
and i went back to my gpmb
positive and negative micrographs and i
could see that those accumulation of
proteins
were present also in the gpmb deficient
mice
and if we analyzed uh the rna
of the phagocytosis in gpnb proficient
versus deficient mice
we could see that the single gene that
is significantly upregulated
during phagocytosis in the gpmb
deficient
so cargo digestion deficient macrophages
is cdkn2a which is indeed
a gene related to cellular senescence
we started then to get our mind around
the concept of immunosome essence
and we discovered that in literature
macrophage immunosenescence it is
described as a condition that appears
with aging
in which macrophages can uh
show an increase pro-inflammatory
profile
and decrease phagocytic capacity so we
became convinced that perhaps what
happens in condition of cargo overload
is that the macrophage undergoes a
premature aging encountering
immunosine essence now if this was
again a phosphostate dependent pathway
we should observe
a similar upregulation of senescence
related genes
in bone marrow derived macrophages while
typomorphorimacrophage is treated
with a pharmacological inhibitor of
phosphostomy
and indeed when we analyzed the rna of
these macrophages
ccnd1 which is another senator related
genes
gene was upregulated in the
phosphorus that we inhibitor treated the
macrophages
the addition of il-10 as a mean to
exogenously stimulate
that rephosphorylation reverted the
increased expression of ccnd1
we also observe a trend for p21 and
another senescence
related gene but we didn't see any
regulation
or up or down regulation of rb1
which is typically a
apoptosis related gene so this really
convinced us
that in the absence of a correct stat
rephosphorylation upon cargo digestion
macrophages undergo immunosome essence
to finally prove it we needed to show
that these macrophages
indeed showed a pro-inflammatory
phenotype
in order to do so we dose the number of
cytokines and chemokines
in the cell culture supernatant coming
from these phagocytosis macrophages
in in the uh column on the left you can
see the
um expression level of various cytokinin
chemokines
of macrophages that do not perform
phagocytosis
as expected um the the macrophages that
perform phagocytosis
correctly uh that is the central bar
in all these graphs um express
lower level of pro-phagocytic molecules
such as
case group mcp1 or mit mp2
however when the same macrophages are
treated with an uh pharmacological
inhibitor
of statutory phosphorylation then
the repression of the prophylactic
uh molecules is completely lost and
indeed
macrophages that are treated with a
phosphostate inhibitor
show an increased
inflammatory profile this further
convinced us
that this was really a pathway that was
worth considering to target
pharmacologically in order to improve
phagocytosis during acute liver injury
however as you may be aware phosphostate
3 controls
a zillion of other functions
and therefore we needed we need a better
understanding
of what is the network of genes and
that is activated by statutory
phosphorylation
downstream starts rephosphorylation in
phagocytosing macrophages
in order to uh to do so um
we used um
a proteomic approach that compared
the proteomic ex the proteomic profile
of the vehicle treated of phosphorous
that three inhibitor treated
uh macrophages from three different mice
the aim was to compare the protein
expression
in the presence or in the absence of the
neuter
among all the proteins that were
detected in this assay
43 of them were expressed in all
of the three uh preparation coming from
the three
uh different mice and therefore we focus
our attention on those
of those uh 1278 protein
85 of them were up or down regulated
in a significant manner
in at least two out of three preparation
and eight of them
were up or down regulated in all of the
three preparation
and what we did first was to use the
sting
uh pathway uh analysis two and we input
all the 85 proteins that were um
up or down regulated in at least two out
of the three samples
and as you can see here most of them are
actually related
which made us think that actually
phosphostatic can be the start
of a very coordinated cellular response
that uh con
that gives riser to a number of the
active to the activation of a number of
different pathways
we then focus further our attention only
on the eight
heads that were up or down regulated in
all the three
um preparations and
we um perform some
gene ontology analysis and we could
see that the
pathway them were mostly regulated as a
consequence of the
statutory uh phosphorylation inhibition
where
pathway had to do with epigenetic
regulation regulation of the smart
pathway
and interestingly regulation of the wind
pathway the wind pathway is relevant
because
our previous phd students in the lab
worked on the role of wind in other
phagocytosis related pathway
during biliary disease which is indeed
another form
of liver disease
we also analyzed
some other parts of that big pathway
that you could see before
and interestingly a part of that pathway
indeed
relates to oxidative stress induced
senescence
which further and independently um
confirm
that the inhibition of foster tree
during phagocytosis
leads to macrophage developing
immunosome essence these are very
preliminary data this is a very recent
experiment it is by no means conclusive
but we hope that by analyzing it further
we can come up
with some interesting uh targets to
[Music]
inhibit or stimulate with a small
molecule
in order to improve the outcome of acute
liver injury
so far our data um
[Music]
prompted us to design this model in
which upon apherocytosis
stat3 is phosphorylated in the
macrophage
and this that rephosphorylation is
instrumental to the activation of
autophagy
which uh prevents the development of
immunosine essence
and promotes the um conversion
of the macrophage from a
pro-inflammatory to an
anti-inflammatory pro-restorative
macrophage which in turn
is a positive
has a positive effect on liver
regeneration however
if the cargo is not adjusted
uh efficiently statory cannot be
phosphorylated
autophagy is cannot be activated or is
activated in a suboptimal manner
and the conversion of the macrophages is
equally not happening or suboptimal
and this has a negative impact on liver
regeneration
the end of this presentation i would
like to thank
all those people without whom this
project wouldn't have been possible in
first place
um first of all my um postdoc supervisor
and mentor professor steve forbes
um all the people in the lab
particularly rona sophia ben
and janet all our external collaborators
all the facilities both at the center
for regenerative medicine and
another center of the university of
edinburgh which is the king's buildings
and the cruc center
all our founders and i thank all of you
for your attention
and i will not be happy to answer your
questions
all right thank you very much lara very
interesting um
i want to make uh one announcement that
i forgot to make at the beginning just
uh while we're waiting for
some questions to come in if any of you
guys are interested
to get more information on the nova site
pention 5 laser flow cytometer
please go to agilent.com and under
products you can click on flow cytometry
and find the instrument there i would
give you the website but it's uh way too
long so
that is the easiest way to find more
information
you'll see some of the um information
that i uh presented here earlier
so um right off the bat um there's one
technical question for you today
lara um it's about your um intracellular
phosphostat 3 stain
are you able to can you kind of explain
how you were able to
stain for phosphorus that stat three in
some of the assay conditions
yeah sure um with an antibody
against phosphostatry particularly
against the thyroid
in position 705 which is the
phosphorylation we are particularly
interested in in this contest
in this context and uh yeah is it
commercially sold by
um a bio legend so we just buy it off
the shelf really
and then we perform first we perform
our cell service staining for cd11b
um as a marker like a general myeloid
marker
which is by no means specific for
macrophages but because we are using
bone marrow derived macrophages is only
macrophages that is there in our cell
culture
and we previously shown that our cell
culture is 99.8
uh macrophage pure so we use cd11b quite
confidently
um we then um fix and permeabilize the
cell
and then we perform the phosphorylation
of that tree
um at the start of this project we had
the performance and immunofluorescence
um which showed that interestingly uh
there is both
a nuclear and the cytoplasmic
localization
of saturday phosphorylation and
our flow protocol specifically
detects the cytoplasmic one and is not a
protocol for nuclear staining
i hope this answered the question yes it
did
thank you um i have another question
um in the context of autophagy and
phagocytosis so do you think this is
more of an
energy demand or is it a like a nutrient
type of demand and if so if it's one of
those do you think that you could rescue
it by
um exogenously supplementing it
yeah that's that's really interesting um
so my feeling is that it's a bit of both
um
this is because um even
like once uh i just literally
um made a mistake and instead of feeding
myself
at different time points i fed them all
together and
so what i did i tried to do sequential
phagocytosis
in which the first phagocytosis didn't
have phosphostate
and the second phagocytosis is d dev
phosphostate
and despite the second phagocytosis
happens in fresh medium
the phagocytosis is still deficient even
if i'm not blocking star tree directly
and even if the medium is fresh so i
think that
there might be a component uh of you
know
nutrients uh need but i think
really what matters uh more here
is probably the cell the cellular stress
that is
um triggered by the um
ingestion of several dead cells at once
so i think it's more of a cellular
response to stress
and one thing i've not mentioned because
it's also quite preliminary but
we think there is also a bit of a
mitochondrial in
uh this function because we see this
very big ballooning
um mitochondria in the
um gpnb deficient macrophages when we
analyze
them by electron microscopy um so
i think it's more an energy deficiency
as more an
energy problem rather than the nutrients
oh very cool yeah it would be um very
interesting to yeah be able to
supplement to
give those cells more energy and then
they could more efficiently
um perform the fact cytosis even without
having the autophagic functions
intact so yeah yeah and it's also
interesting i think that
the cells need to activate phytostatosis
at a very specific time point so
something that i'm not showed
here today but we're including in the
paper is that if we
um pre-induce um autophagy
by for example removing uh the
serum from the medium before exposing
the macrophages to
to to the meal and the macrophages are
still
are again inefficient for phagocytosis
so
it seems that it has to be really timed
and we think that these kind of timers
can be phosphostatry so the first the
the phosphorylation star tree
ah very interesting very nice thank you
we have a couple of
questions coming in regarding some of
the flow cytometry
assay the 24 color panel that i
mentioned in the very beginning and
just because that'll take up quite a bit
of time and there's so many markers that
were used i will
follow up with those uh questions over
email
um there's another question that has
come in in terms of uh senescence
how would you define senescence in a how
do you define senescence in the
in a post-mitotic cell kind of like the
the macrophages
yeah that's that's a very good question
so normally when we think of immunos in
essence we think of t
cells that become unable to do clonal
expansion or less efficient
to doing clonal expansion and actually
it has been shown that macrophages in
elderly patients are less efficient for
phagocytosis
and are more pro-inflammatory a concept
that has recently
been crystallized with the term
inflammation
so the fact that as we progress in age
the our body becomes a progressively
more pro-inflammatory
environment because of these lack of
modulation that
phagocytosis brings on the innate immune
system
and um some studies have correlated this
with some
chronic um conditions that are typically
um appearing with aging as well um so
what we think it happens here
is that even if you're in your 20s but
you take an overdose of paracetamol
um the liver undergoes such a
massive necrosis and intense oxidative
stress
that the macrophages become old
and in turn in meaning that they become
less efficient
in performing phagocytosis and they
become more pre-inflammatory thereby
becoming part of the problem instead of
part of the resolution of the problem
and that's why we think that's a very
interesting target
in the context of this disease
uh okay thank you um there's another
question that came in and i think you
um touched on it on uh one slide with
some of the other publications but
do you also see where where else in the
in the body are we seeing these
this link between autopha the autophagy
requirement for efficient phagocytosis
by the macrophages
sorry can you repeat the question please
yeah so
um the the question is are there other
uh organs or um
places in the body where um phagocytosis
is dependent on autophagy
or maybe other um other contexts in
terms of
disease or challenges or
injury that you can elaborate on
yeah i've phagocytosis has been shown to
be instrumental for example to prevent
bacterial colonization in lungs um
so patients that have chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease
have um less efficient macrophages
like in terms of phagocytosis and they
are indeed exposed to turning
to recurrent bacterial infections
um i've now mentioned here for sake of
time but
um also in acute liver injury one of the
major problem in our patients
is that they um show an increased
translocation of bacteria
from the gut to the circulation because
the liver
normally is a barrier for those bacteria
and because the macrophages are less
efficient performing phagocytosis
they can't perform this barrier function
anymore um
not necessarily linked to autophagy but
phagocytosis is
like a deficient phagocytosis that's
been linked also
in to the pathogenesis
of some autoinflammatory autoimmune
diseases such as
systemic lupus erythematosus and that's
because
the that cell remain um
around and move from
apoptosis to secondary necrosis and they
release the interest
their intracellular content and this um
kind of perpetrates and and then further
release its inflammation and and they
in them the following inflammatory in
sorry immunological response
and so yeah that's those are two other
examples
um i think someone made a very
interesting
comment here saying don't forget that
autophagy
is also part of the reparative process
in which cells have the opportunity and
time to do what they need to do
and i totally agree with that and
in fact i we think that the reason
um these autophagys kicks in during
phagocytosis that
normally these would have been uh
designed
to um give the macrophage the time
to digest and deal with all the
internalized
cargo and to then progress and eat more
cells
so definitely this we think this is a
how it has
um kind of physiologically evolved
and what it has physiologically evolved
for um
we just think that it may be
dysfunctional in the case of acute liver
injury just because
of this combination of a very high level
of cell death
and a very oxidative environment
okay yeah that's a that's a great point
thank you
so all right uh any other questions
coming in from the audience
let's see
all right i think that's all we have for
now um
please let's thank laura compania i
really appreciate
your talk it was very interesting and i
hope you enjoy the rest of your day
everybody
thank you